So far we've focused on explaining
the basics of how to virtualize
efficiently the CPU, but
let's now look at the other types of
resources looking at memory first.
We will explain how memory
virtualization can be achieved for
the two basic virtualization approaches,
whether it's based on
full virtualization, or
requires guest modification and we will
talk about full virtualization first.
For full virtualization a key
requirement is that the guest operating
system continues to observe a contiguous
linear physical address space
that starts from physical address zero,
this is what an operating system with
c if it actually own the physical memory
and run natively on physical hardware.
To achieve this we distinguish
among three types of addresses,
virtual addresses, so
these are the ones that are used
by the applications in the guest.
Physical addresses, these are the ones
that the guest thinks are the addresses
of the physical resource and the machine
addresses, these are the actual machine
addresses with the actual physical
addresses on the underlying platform.
The similar distinction of virtual
verses physical verses machine will also
apply to the page numbers and
the page frame numbers.
So given this, the guest operating
system can continue make mappings of
virtual addresses to of the physical
addresses that it thinks it owns,
and then underneath that
the hypervisor will then pick
these physical addresses that the guests
believes are the real ones and
map them to the real machine addresses.
So in a sense they're two page tables,
one that's maintained by the guest
operating system, and another one
that's maintained by the hypervisor.
Now remember that at the hardware level,
we have a number of mechanisms,
the memory management unit, the TLB
caching of the address translations,
that these mechanisms help with
the address translation process,
make it much more efficient, and
don't require us, in software,
to repeatedly perform address
translations and validations.
Now this option that we discussed so
far will require that every
single memory access goes through
two separate translation, the first
one which will be done in software,
and then the second one potentially
can take advantage of hardware
resources like TLB because the hardware
will understand only this page table.
Clearly this will be too expensive
since this will add over hands on
every single memory reference,
it will slow down the ability to
run at near native hardware speeds.
The second option is for the hypervisor
to maintain a shadow page table,
in which it actually looks at what
are the virtual addresses that
the guests has mapped to
these physical addresses.
And then in the shadow page
table it directly establishes
a mapping between the virtual addresses
that are used by the guest, and
the machine addresses that are used by
the hypervisor by the physical hardware.
Then if the hardware MMU uses this
page table, the guest operating system
is allowed to execute natively using the
applications will use virtual addresses,
and these will be directly translated
to the machine addresses that are,
used by the physical hardware.
The hypervisor will clearly have to be
responsible to maintain consistence
between these two page tables and it
will have to employ mechanism that for
instance invalidate,
what is the currently valid page tables,
shadow page table whenever there is a,
context wedge or
to write protect the guest page table,
in order to keep track of new mappings
that the guest operating system
install since similar mechanism.
This write protection is necessary so
that whenever the guest OS tries to
install new virtual to physical
address mapping in the page
tables that are used by the guest, this
will cause a trap to the hypervisor,
and then the hypervisor will be able
to pick up that virtual address and
then associate the corresponding
machine address and
insert this mapping into the page table
that is used by the hardware MMU.
This can be done completely
transparently to the guest
operating system.